good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is John let's go I'm happy to
welcome you to Columbia University to a
conference that we are holding today and
tomorrow on dealing with the past in
east-central europe it's a subject that
comes out of our involvement with two
foundations one in New York one in
Warsaw the critical foundation and the
semper Polonia foundation which support
some of the things that we do at the
East European Center that deal with
Poland the topic was part of a series of
events that we had been thinking about
for quite some time and frankly when we
began to think about it there was a
different government in Warsaw one that
would be pursuing some of the things
we're going to be talking about a lot
more energetically than the current
government will and as we began to think
about illustration about the politics of
history about historical justice we
began to to contextualize it so in the
Polish case we thought a little bit
about how important the dialogue was
between poles and Ukrainians just last
May and the second third of many of this
year we had a conference on on polish
German reconciliation which is an
ongoing process just as polish Ukrainian
reconciliation is and then we started to
think about what happened in other
countries we start to think about
illustration in Germany so the veces
lust trading the vocs we thought about
what happened in the Czech Republic what
did not happen in Hungary and what is
just beginning to happen in Romania and
in other countries and of course the
whole issue of justice in transition is
something that each country is
experiencing just as each country in
Europe and elsewhere is looking at its
own history very differently which led
us to a series of questions about
how Germans are beginning to re-examine
themselves as victims of the Second
World War and not as the people who
started that conflict we were beginning
to ask questions about state policy in
the area of Education which is something
I hope that we pursue today and tomorrow
how to what extent should a state like
Poland mandate education in the form of
looking at for example heroic deeds like
the babolat investor plata in September
of 1939 and the wars are rising in 1944
visa V yet verb net the tragedy at the
involvement and a different way of
looking at the Warsaw izing in 1944 to
begin our exploration of some of these
topics we turned to Professor John
elster who teaches here in the
Department of Political Science at
Columbia University where he is the
Robert K Merton professor of social
sciences professor at Ulster has a lot
of books to his credit one of which is
of particular interest to us here which
is called closing the books transitional
justice in historical perspective which
was published three years ago and was
something that Professor Elster had been
working on with a team of people here at
the University for years before and this
evening he's going to begin our
conference with the discussion entitled
reflections on a transition and frankly
I can't think of anybody better to
tackle the topic professor Ulster
thank you John let me start by saying
that as a non-specialist in an audience
of specialists I feel slightly
intimidated so I have to beg for your
charity and indulgence which does not
mean that you should spare your
criticism but charitable criticism now
I'm going to present some mainly quite
personal reflections on the transitions
that took place in almost all communist
countries around nineteen ninety our
main talk about Central and Eastern
Europe which are no best will also refer
to the Soviet Union and briefly to China
and to Cuba some of the talk will be
just personal reminiscences but some
will be about transitions these
transitions in general and some more
specifically about the topic of this
conference transitional justice or
dealing with the past
mic closer well then I'm okay let me see
cuz they're not I have to read my
manuscript so how is this better okay
now of course the issue of transitions
and ease of transitional justice are
related in many ways notably because the
features of the sensations shape the
modalities of transitional justice
itself topic 2 which I will return
several times now I've been thinking
about this for some time I wrote my
first article on topic in the longer
london review book on january 25 1990
and this was more or less in the middle
of transition but the dust had settled
enough for it to be possible to see the
way in which things were moving the
title of that article was when communism
dissolves maybe should have been when
communism implodes then later that year
in june nineteen ninety I invited myself
to a conference that I heard was going
to take place in pitch in hungary on
institution building in the new
societies in the new regimes and at the
conference where among others Victor
ohshit in ski and Andhra Shia and I was
immediately struck by the depths of
their insights at the conference also by
a lucky accident was the Dean of the
University of Chicago Law School I was
teaching in Chicago at a time Jared
caster and I asked Garrett well what
about creating a center to study these
ongoing constitutional developments and
they said sure I often wish that my
institution here was as had the same
mode of flexible and Swift
decision-making
now when I came back to Chicago Stephen
Holmes who is now at NYU Law School Cass
Sunstein who remains at chicago and i
created a center for the study of
constitutionalism in Eastern Europe our
first task was to recruit collaborators
to the center in the former communist
countries in Eastern Europe so in the
winter of 1991 Stephen Holmes and I
traveled around central Eastern Europe
to Prague sofia sofia Bratislava
Belgrade Zagreb and Jana to locate
suitable collaborators and mostly with
success it was one poignant case in
which a person accepted to be our
collaborator but then a week later wrote
to us that after your visit to me i had
another visit so i have to go back on my
commitment you can probably understand
why teen years later I met him again he
was then very prominent academically and
he said it was very ashamed or what he
had done and I said that was ridiculous
because of course was no reason why he
should put his collaboration with us
ahead or his own personal security well
I could go on like this but what I want
there was a lot of traveling in those
years mainly related to
constitution-making but of course when
we talk to politicians in a region the
issues of transitional justice always
came up so in a way indirectly I was
preparing myself for the book that John
mentioned that i published some years
ago one thing I've been struck by ever
since was how the transitions in Eastern
Europe constituted a massive failure for
the Social Sciences attention nobody
predicted the rapid and total collapse
of communist
in the region there were some exceptions
and it will be interesting to try to
identify them and see if they were right
for the right reasons princes I remember
that in 1978 Ln character donkus wrote
the book in which she predicted the
downfall of the Soviet Union or the
breakup of the Soviet Union due to
ethnic tensions well she was right about
the downfall but I think wrong about the
course now another failure was even more
striking that appeared in couple years
later I think that in the years of 1989
1990 and 1991 to my best knowledge not a
single person anywhere predicted the
rapid return of Communists to power in
the region communist governments and
covering calmness presidents and when I
reread my article from 1990 in the non
or review books I find various
expressions of skepticism about reform
but not a single hint that the
Communists might actually have come back
and I'm happy to be corrected but during
my years traveling at that time I don't
think a single person brought up this
possibility and I think maybe we all
were under the sway of a false analogy
from the post-1945 events when of course
National Socialism was eliminated
completely as a political factor so
maybe we thought just axiomatically that
communism to would be completely
eliminated well I don't know what
explanation was that I think the facts
are clear and let me just mention that
in this respect the transitions rated
1989 fall into the same pattern of
various various other world historical
events exception nobody predicted the
Independence of the American colonists
an essential nobody predicted the French
Revolution there are exceptions I can
cite a couple in 1765 the kings
ministers result in France predicted
American independence and in 1770
Thiago's advisor a bearded le predicted
very firmly the French Revolution but
these were exceptions so by and large
these came as a total surprise on the
inevitable in hindsight now let me take
a smaller press press more interesting
example all the difficulties or
prediction related to a crucial stage in
the transition may be the very beginning
on transition namely the elections in
June 1989 in Poland I think at a time
there well I think the sweeping victory
or the opposition of solidarity in those
elections where perhaps the decisive
event in the whole sequence of
transitions and totally utterly are
predicted by the regime which will never
have accepted elections if their
predicted if it by solidarity and by
outside observers the highly respected
and well informed Louisa Winton wrote in
Radio Free Europe on march twenty
nineteen eighty nine that the need for
the government to win some of the free
seats in the same to override a veto of
a Senate was quote likely to be more
important in principle than in practice
because the communists in fact would
only have to get ate out of 161 free
seats to override a veto by the salad
but as we know they did not get a single
seat and I remember vividly when this
happened and I told myself this is the
beginning of the end then I remembered
that I heard that phrase before 20 years
earlier but forgotten it when I was
doing my dissertation work in Paris
around nineteen seventy my dissertation
supervisor rimowa Rome reacted to the
news about uprising in Gdansk in
december seven nineteen seventy with
that
race this is the beginning of the end
and of course it was right but maybe not
for the right reasons Iroh had a very
strong record of prediction among French
intellectuals he was the only one who
said strongly and ambiguously as early
as 1957 that Algerian independence was
inevitable and I'm not sure he diagnosed
the reason for the collapse of communism
correctly because as I understood
understood understand those reasons they
were largely related to the massive
economic inefficiency and wastefulness
all those regimes so maybe our home and
Harold uncle's got it right that maybe
not for the right reasons now let me
just insert a brief irrelevant aside
about Cuba to show the difficult is no
prediction I went to Cuba for a short
visit with colleague Adam Jaworski in
1994 and when I came back I wrote up a
report predicting the imminent demise of
communism in Cuba I said that
intellectuals and the elite in general
were engaged in what you might call a
calculus on descent choosing the optimal
moment to show their colors late enough
to avoid punishment and early enough to
escape the charge of opportunism well
that may have been true but a regime
still seem to be hanging in so
let me move away from these anecdotes
and try to say something more systematic
about transitions and I'll organize my
remarks in seven points 7 features of
these transitions in 1989 1990 91 in
central a yeast is the new Europe and to
some extent in the Soviet you know first
we must never forget i think the unique
nature of this transition communism was
you might say a 70 year long parenthesis
in world history was closed in 1989 1990
and I think it's relatively safe to
predict that it will never be opened
again it may be the most radical regime
change in world history when a dynasty
falls another dynasty more or less like
it takes a place when a fascist or
authoritarian regime Falls that doesn't
prevent another such regime primer izing
later in another country even in the
same country when a democracy false that
doesn't apply the phone of democracy but
in the case of communism defined largely
through central planning I think the
demise he is definitive it's hard to
imagine that anyone would ever
deliberately adopt this wasteful in a
patient system again now giving what I
just said about difficulties or
prediction I might of course be wrong
but it is at least for beyond my powers
of imagination now the second point is
need to distinguish transitions to
democracy and restoration of democracy
the dynamics in countries and Central
Europe differ from those of eastern
europe and soviet union in which
democracy and rule of law had
essentially never existed so this is one
reason why
see I'm think I got mine
I think I'm actually just deleted some
of one of my points but that's okay okay
so maybe I should back up a little one
of the difficult of a prediction has to
do with the fact that we can observe
what the transitions are transitions
from but we do not know yet for some
countries what they were transitions to
so we know in in Central Europe that
we're transitions to market economists
and two democracies but you do not
really know what is going on in Russia
or in China we know that there are
transitions to market economists but we
cannot really predict the outcome of
future political developments you know
wen Chou Enlai was asked what he thought
about the French Revolution he allegedly
said it it's too early to tell and
similarly it may be too early to tell
what the political long-term equilibrium
effects of the transition in the former
Soviet Union will be but I think it's
one reason is so hard to make that
prediction is that as I said the had
never been democracy and the rule of law
in a Soviet Union so these institutions
could not serve as a focal point to
which to return everything has to be
invented from scratch
now a third point which has often been
made is that these transitions were
almost unique in regime changes in that
they occurred virtually without any
violence it wasn't just a Czechoslovak
transition that was available revolution
the same was true of all the countries
in the region there was no street
fighting and except for the execution of
the child chess skills there was no wild
justice it is rumored that the German
Democratic Republic contemplated using
violence in imitation of the so-called
Chinese model from Tiananmen but the
fact is that they didn't and perhaps the
East German leaders were afraid that
soldiers would not obey orders to fire
all the crowds and this lack awareness
during the transition was matched by
lack of violence prior to the transition
although they were of course
oppositional or dissident movements more
or less organized in all the countries
except for Romania there was no armed
underground resistance no assassinations
of officials no sabotage the uprising or
confrontations of 1953 1956 1968 and
1970 were not the work on organized and
the ground or position and one
interesting implication of the lack of
violence for transitional justice is
that the husband Lee have been there has
been no reason to ask whether the
purchase or the punishments should be
even-handed that is as in South Africa
where both a and C and the regime have
been both members of NC and leaders of
the regime had been brought in before
the Truth and Reconciliation Commission
because in the region we are talking
about all the atrocities were committed
by one site by the government
question of even-handedness never came
up a fourth remarkable feature of the
transition that I remember very vividly
following you know as we all did day by
day week by week was the snowballing
that took place within countries and
across countries if these incisions in
portland hungary East Germany
Czechoslovakia and Bulgaria happened in
a cascade each one of them shaping
expectations in the next month and the
build-up of street demonstrations in
Leipzig on successive Sundays in October
1989 also had a snowballing pattern
although i'm sure the underlying
mechanisms were different and i think
this is another challenge to the social
sciences we don't quite understand this
phenomenon of colic contagion imitation
snowballing technical language symbols
call it Bayesian updating but you don't
really understand it another instance
was the diffusion of the French 1848
revolution first Germany and then
throughout Europe exactly how does this
happen it's an interesting challenge and
I think we don't quite understand it a
fifth observation which is a bit more
speculative well the fact is not
speculative with the explanation I'm
going to suggest might be a bit
speculative the fact is that at the same
time as the transitions took place all
the Federation's in the region brought
up in fixed revatio Yugoslavia and the
Soviet Union and this is must be more
than a coincidence but I do not know
whether it simply was that all the
breakups or the Federation's had a
common cause that is the damn pool or
communism or whether some kind of
snowballing effect might have taken
place there
as well well as I said this is
speculative
a more complex conceptual point concerns
the coexistence of transition and
continuity making a clean break with the
past is difficult if in making the break
when employs the methods and a
conceptual framework of the past itself
and let me just give one illustration
from the satirical work of Alexander
synovia shinobi observes the following
that until nineteen fifty three in the
Soviet Union it was obligatory to
mention Stalin and all possible and
impossible context then there was a
brief period between 1950 356 when it
was permissible not to mention Stalin
and then F 1956 it became obligatory not
to mention it and soon other claims that
this confusion with all this inference
from that whatever is not mandatory is
forbidden is a peculiarly Stalinist
mindset that was employed in the process
of these salinization itself and I
believe Patrick Hubbard was warning
against such hidden continuities in his
famous mantra we are not like them well
sometimes they the new regimes way like
their predecessors in a Czech Republic
in particular it seems to me that the
desire for revenge against those that
violate in the rule of law in the past
was some times stronger than respect for
the rule of law itself another hidden
continuity is found in the insistence on
positive rights and welfare rights in
many constitutions in Central and
Eastern Europe although these clauses
may have been inserted as make-believe
concessions they Harbor magnifications
been used our constitutional courts to
strike down legislation another such
hidden continuity can be seen in
processes of restitution
we're in Romania and I think maybe also
Bulgaria for a while at least there
there was a limit on the size of land
that people could receive as a result of
the process of restitution clearly a
legacy of the egalitarian ideology of
the past and a final may be more obvious
from the more important form of
continuity is the survival of the
nomenklatura in some countries the
persistence of communist trained judges
and prosecutors has been a serious
obstacle to transitional justice just as
the persistence of Nazi judges was in
Germany after 1945 so what these remarks
add up to is the implication that the
continuity of the pack with the past may
cause transitional justice to be adding
more severe well more lenient than would
otherwise have been the case depending
on whether there's a desire for revenge
or whether the survival of the old
communist judges and prosecutors are
turn out to be most important
so my last point was actually one that I
made a bit earlier because I got mixed
up in my numbering other points namely
that transition is not just transition
from but also transition to and that
often in these cases and some of them
will not know what there is a transition
to and i would like to quote something
tocumen wrote in 1850s he said I already
had heard it said in my lifetime on four
occasions that this new society made by
revolution had now find has no finally
found its natural and permanent form
four times events afterwards proved that
people were wrong so in Russia and China
I don't think Meredith paint this area
Oh what will be the natural and
permanent form of the new political
system the dust is very far from settled
and I'm going to make a similar point
with respect to the main topic of this
conference dealing with the past so let
me just summarize the tasks that the new
regime faced after transition there are
two forward-looking tasks building a
canoe the transition to a market economy
and building a constitutional democracy
and one backward-looking task
translational justice retribution
purchase restitution compensation and so
now the need for the forward-looking or
the importance of the forward-looking
tasks was obvious from the beginning but
in need for the backward looking task
was not obvious and here i can just
testify on the basis of my own
experience by cycling from the notes i
wrote up for myself just my private use
after the patch Conference in 1919 here
is what i wrote several politicians
present at a conference agreed that
retribution should not be carried out
except against those had committed clear
criminal acts such as torture the
spanish solution or complete amnesty was
the only workable all the injustice
inherent in amnesty was the price one
had to pay for democracy later we still
quoting the issue of rectification
giving back property to the author
Muhammad had been confiscated was raised
again the general tendency was to argue
against this form or backward-looking
justice so this was in june nineteen
ninety i do not know whether this was
representative a lot but at least that's
what we heard and the word the spanish
model was certainly very frequently used
to the phrase spanish model but as you
know this is not how things turn out in
most of the region in Poland and in
Hungary the Spanish model was held up as
something to imitate for a while but
except to some extent in Hungary this
did not last very long
but here is another failure prediction
if we go back to the early 1990s a mid
nineteen nineties i do not think anyone
would have predicted that retribution or
illustration would have been a live
issue in poland in 2007 because i think
we all were under the impression that
these emotions the desire for revenge
would not fade with time as many
emotions do but we learned from his new
Europe and from Argentina and Chile that
in fact these emotions can remain very
strong for decades now going on almost
go in Argentina actually more than 20
years in Shilla almost and is nirav
almost 20 years so that was another
prediction that nobody made we thought
that if there was going to be
transitional justice it will be switched
over and done with and then move forward
as what happened after 1945 well that's
definitely not what has happened well at
least in Poland to take the paradigmatic
example as John mentioned it
let me step back a little bit to review
my own thinking on a topic at a time
what I saw recommended on normative
grounds I had a discussion Herman's
watch about retribution and compensation
and Herman argued I think quite
vigorously for quite strong retribution
and generous compensation and argued
against him saying that the big fish
will probably be hard to catch punishing
only the small fish will be unfair and
that compensating everybody when
everybody had suffered would be like
asking people to take in in each other's
laundry and Herman said that one should
at least do what one could so I publish
an article in East European
constitutional review in 1992 called
doing what one can that is also partly
reprinted in the first of the three of
audience on transitional justice edited
by the u.s. Institute of Peace where I
essentially said the following because
nobody was innocent nobody should be put
on trial because everybody suffered
nobody should be compensated the
dispensing of retributive and consent
compensatory justice make sense only on
the background of an otherwise orderly
society at the very least prosecutors
and judges and officials must come with
clean hands these conditions are not
satisfied in a former communist
countries well I still more or less
believe in these propositions with
exceptions to be sure of tortures their
victims and probably some other
categories of individuals who gave
orders to shoot to kill but
in a way this is not how things worked
out in a Czech Republic and in pollen
maybe other countries to lists of
alleged collaborators where the security
police have been posted on internet
numbers of individuals ranging I think
in a five or maybe even six figures I
wonder how many kill themselves when
they found themselves on that list I
only one example which is in the spring
of nineteen ninety-eight an unknown
organization in Lublin in Poland person
named 119 persons read allegedly
cooperated with the militia before
nineteen eighty nine and two of those
named individuals subsequently kill
themselves now what I've just said no no
well there is a pony sociologist k you
see cook k you see cook who is published
a book in French on this which I read
and he claims that it's interesting
because it's in prayer but never in
Polish but I a lot of time about suicide
computed by this but I was searching but
about now about 17 years and I haven't
found any examples for ABI have to
ourselves but my now I know I don't as I
tried to verify the credentials of me to
cook he seemed to be a bonnet either
scholar so I took his word maybe I
shouldn't have but he I cited minima in
my book on translational justice but it
was published in french written in
french i believe so well
well let me just say one thing shame is
one of the most powerful motivators for
suicide being held up exposed even if
unjustly as having committed a shameful
act is a very strong inducement to
suicide and I can cite many examples and
but it says it's a on a priori grounds I
would be surprised if the application of
those lists did not induce some people
who perhaps in some vague way we're
guilty or something to maybe in a
precise way to to kill themselves but of
course that's the empirical issue and of
course I might be wrong now what I have
just said amounts to autumn are called
post-transition arguments for leniency
or punishment but then there's not a
issue on the set of arguments that arise
before the transition because sometimes
to make the transition possible at all
you may have to promise amnesty immunity
or at least leniency to the Arcturian
leaders otherwise they might not want to
step down and as we know this is what
happened in South Africa the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission was a
compromise because the white government
would not step down if they could be
expected to be brought to justice and
the processes of transitional justice in
Argentina Chile and Uruguay were also
heavily constrained by the outgoing
military regimes and there have been
many claims that transitional justice in
central Eastern Europe or so so
constrained by the need to guarantee
immunity to the outcoming leaders and in
my book eyesight half a dozen
allegations to this effect mainly
relating to Poland and Hungary but they
do not really add up to hard evidence
there seems to be another year that was
an implicit
contract an implicit tacit agreement
that the outgoing leaders would not be
prosecuted the tacit promise which the
leaders believe what if there was it has
a promise and if the outcoming leaders
believed it they made a mistake because
it's a natural democracy that anyone
negotiating on behalf of the state
cannot make promises for what subsequent
courts or legislators or their own
successors might do so even if the left
wing of solidarity said Pakistan serve
under the right thing of solidarity did
not feel any need to keep the promises
made by the left wing so it's a puzzle
to me why the outgoing leaders did not
understand this elementary implication
of rational choice theory now in Hungary
according to my former student at
Columbia john simon who wrote his
doctoral dissertation on a round table
in hungary there was another
pre-transition mechanism that brought
about not exactly munity but at least
attenuated punishment which is following
the hungarian communist leaders in 1989
said temporal october maybe same 1989
we're quite unsure but what would happen
in upcoming elections the first free
election so they decided to hedge their
bets and try to put in place an
electoral law that would maximize their
chance or having a majority in new
parliament but also in case they lost in
the first Parliament to have a
constitutional court a strong
Constitutional Court that could be
expected to strike down punitive
legislation and that is a guess more or
less what happened was a farsighted act
on the part of the outcoming communists
to create a court that the strike down
legislation to
punish them now I would like to mention
one final point I talked product between
already the reverberations of the 1945
transitions in 1989 I think there are
many complex interesting links between
transitional justice or transitional non
justice in 1945 and the events in 1989
let me just mention three reactions I
heard from German friends or site German
friends citing what they had heard among
other friends one was very reaction
inspired or motivated by charges that
Germany did too little after 1945 namely
this time they're going to get it right
another reaction was inspired by
resentment that German in 1945 was
punished for fighting communism and that
reaction took the form of saying this
time we are going to be on top and the
third reaction I heard which seems to me
the most recent lubang wall said it will
be unreasonable to impose stricter
punishments on communist crimes than on
the in Germany infinitely more serious
not see crowds but as you also know in
Hungary and Poland these two is two
episodes are also heavy heavily mixed up
with a long okay thank you
Thank You professor Elster we have time
for questions Chris or cuspid in school
if anybody else would like to ask a
question may i ask you kindly to use the
mic now my questions concerning the case
of germany because you mentioned this on
the end of your speech because it's it's
there it's the country which dealt more
consequently with with the commons
passed and my questions was it not
democratic they put in jpg on cranson
and so on and there was a also other
justification of this move namely that
there are all subject the democracy and
flow rules of law applied as you know
probably nobody now sleep in social
sciences remained from GD are professors
at universities after unification so
this is my questions when you think
germany is a democratic country yeah why
you know this strategy you can accept
you know this kind of deal inquisitive
with the past which is using much more
and the second question is the second
questions do you apply your think
because you are we are talking about
transition generally but there are some
theories which apply this to you know
each change from undemocratic regime of
totalitarianism to the Democratic one so
would you the same salt apply and this
you would you advocate the same strategy
concerning the transition from national
socialism to democracy or not well I
will try to respond when I think the
transition from national socialist to
democracy you know was a transition from
an autocracy autocratic regime to a
democratic ones I didn't really
understand the distinction in my book I
discussed one case of transitions to
monarchy namely from Napoleon to the do
the 18th in 1815 but most of the cases
or transitional justice in history have
been following the transitions to
democracy there's one other example in
the opposite direction which is what
happened in England in 1660 where the
return of charges the second and and the
treatment of the Regicides now the first
question about transitional justice in
Germany is it's very complex partly
because it was constrained by the
agreement reached in the negotiations
that only crimes on the acts that were
crimes and both West German an East
German law could be pursued so that was
one issue then another issue was the way
this worked out in practice I refer to
the article by cloths offer and Arica
papa in a book edited that came out last
year retribution and restitution in
transitions to democracy where they show
the intestinal a small percentage of
cases investigated that were actually
actually led to someone going to prison
I'm not really sure whether it was
anything undemocratic in German
transitional justice maybe you could
elaborate on the it maybe I
misunderstood you because if you think
there was anything undemocratic about
translational justice in Germany after
1989 I would like to perhaps know
exactly what you had in mind I think it
I don't think it was a good process I
think the purchase in the administration
where by and large successful and that
includes of course the purchase of
teachers a Marxist marxism-leninism in
universities I think that was an
appropriate purge but I think more
people should probably should have been
like a gong crunched sentenced to to
prison but as I said
I don't know whether any of these flows
if the word floss can be traced back to
any Democratic deficiencies
slightly different context but it's very
much in the news right now China and
it's not the subject matter but it's
very interesting when you consider in 76
there was a Cultural Revolution which
was sort of close to let's say the Paris
Commune it was as close to an Alec
egalitarian moment you know that one of
would have had China now is going
through and I do a lot of work in this
and insecurities analysis they're making
billionaires not millionaires in the
most shameless 19th century robber baron
way and this hasn't happened in Europe
other than in Russia and even there it's
sort of somewhat limited and in some
cases it hasn't even really properly
gone forward in China it's just going
forward massively and I've just be
interested in your reflection of how
something like this could be happening I
think back in 76 which isn't a very long
time ago and to see this Delta this
extreme Delta occurring right before our
eyes and nobody's mention much about it
so considered fully acceptable and the
way things are well the way I understand
this question in the present context is
the following suppose there is a real
democratic revolution in China like as
their walls for instance in Korea some
years ago when former autocrats where
held responsible could it happen in
China that the people responsible for
the things for the actions and outcomes
you just described could be held
responsible and
I don't think so it's it's when
societies deal with their past the acts
the focus on our well let me think for a
second of course they wear German firms
that or leaders of German firms that
were convicted and jailed F 1945 for use
of slave labor and and other practices
but but it I would say by a large the
active describe fall outside the normal
scope of transitional justice it it
might not fall outside the scope of
Criminal Justice assuming that there is
no statute of limitation but that is a
different issue ask this but you
mentioned germany after 1945 some
wondering if you feel comfortable
commenting on what happened with Japan
after World War Two in 1945 in Japan
they were first an international
criminal tribunal and then there were
separate tribunals organized by the
victorious powers I what I'm trying to I
think the most striking fact if you
compare the Japanese war trials with a
German war Charles was the extensive use
in Japan of strict liability the courts
did not require proof of what legal
scholars called mens rea oh that is
intentions and beliefs so even when a
Japanese general was unaware that his
soldiers were committing atrocities and
if they had been aware would have been
unable to do anything about it the
mere fact that they wear under his
normal command made him liable so that
is what in legal context is called
strict liability it's often used in this
country with respect to dangerous
products produced by firms they are held
strictly liable even if no intention or
negligence can be can be proved so I
think that was one main difference one
similarity was at in Germany and in
Japan the Cold War made the whole
process diverge or maybe brought it to a
halt so the doctors on some aspects yeah
better yes my question is about your to
citation and the first one was said
xenovia that mandatory was mentioned the
greatest father starting between 53 and
56 I think 1933 and 56 yeah maybe
in many books he was the greatest
teacher father that said this is first
question which talk mighty not yet yeah
because this is Alexandra synovial
version of it thank you this seconds you
know yes the dissident Alexander
synovial was a logician actually a
classmate of Gorbachev for his life yeah
but I am surprised that he didn't know
that this started the thirties yeah yeah
after two 1953 he lifted up to 19 people
up to the sighting quoting stallion and
all possible and impossible impossible
context was mandatory then for three
years it was permissible not to do so
and then after 56 was obligatory not to
do something that's what I was saying
okay and the second question is about
this publication on the internet was so
shameful for some person they are
suicide we probably nobody to hear about
this situation in Poland and maybe last
small question comment of course
illustration is very old process and was
in Imperium Romanum and allegiance came
from wars they didn't obey and Roman law
at the sewer and in Rome a legend state
outside Rome and was in the first who
broke this was a Julius Caesar and he
paid the highest price and of course a
small question commented illustration in
Poland was deferred injured in Germany
was made from outside from by Western
pro career prosecutors and of course in
Poland was the greatest problem because
40 million people country and over 1
million portfolios of course the
greatest an apocalyptic illustration in
history maybe
we'll be in China this will be about 200
million folders yeah well on the
question of suicides it's obviously an
empirical issue I gather that nobody
here from Poland or the Czech Republic
if there is anyone where there was also
published a list has heard about this I
can only note what you're saying but I
will repeat that well let me just give a
simple example in 1996 the French police
made a massive raid against consumers of
pedophilic material six of whom kill
themselves when they were exposed well
that was shameful to be sure to be
exposed as a consumer of your affiliate
material wouldn't it be just a shameful
to be exposed as having be frayed your
friend your wife your colleagues at work
or otherwise or being such Ben suspected
having done these things as I said I'm
just thinking from first principles
there are some suspicions that are so
safe shame inducing that they often lead
to suicide so that's all I can say and
then there are these two references from
the book the Bible can give the exact
title here it is kept k UK is firstly
malicious maybe he'll let Poland the
post-communist my auntie communism the
Paris 2001 in a very respectable
publishing house so he says after 119
individuals renamed to kill themselves
well maybe is right maybe is wrong how
can I know now respect the illustration
and purchase in the public
administration is nothing new you know
it's I think for the situation to be
consistent with rule of law there has to
be their number of conditions that had
to be fulfilled there have to be a
presumption of innocence there has to be
individual proof of wrongdoings
not group wrongdoings there has been
appeals procedure and so on and so forth
many of these conditions were not
fulfilled in central Eastern Europe
after 1989 but after 1945 in the german
occupied countries they were purchased
in the administration's our people had
collaborated with a german occupying
power and in which case these conditions
that are just enumerated we're in fact
satisfied so that is why I think that
Hubble's principle we are not like them
is important because it implies that we
treat those who violate the rule of law
by applying the rule of law and you know
i'm sure this famous statement by a east
german dissident after the fall of the
wall we thought we would get justice but
we only got the rest start of a master
which one short comment and two short
questions regarding these alleged
victims of agents lists in Poland or in
czech republic i must say that i tried
to follow these problems very closely
for many years and I haven't heard I
haven't read about any single person who
committed suicide in Poland in republic
in or in Germany I think this is sort of
a black legend of illustration a song
and now two short questions listening to
your very brilliant speech I had an
impression that you say that any kind of
retribution is somehow close to revenge
but what about the meaning of revealing
the truth and achieving the dusties this
is the question not about facts but
about values and the question about
facts is you mentioned a ver example of
the Spanish model of
coming to terms with legacy of a
dictatorship and you said that this
model was adopted in Poland and in
Hungary for a brief period of time how
will you comment that this model
collapsed now in Spain and this is 70
years after the end of the Civil War and
this is 30 years after the collapse of
the Franco regime so this is the example
of this country where people seek you
can call it revenge or true for justice
even after much longer time but it
happened in in Poland and in Eastern
Europe well let me begin with the last
question I think what is happening in
Spain today is on a very small scale
compared to what we've been talking
about I don't think there's been any
call for sending anyone to to jail you
know remember the Civil War ended as I
said 70 years ago and if you fought in
that war must be in there you know late
80s or early 90s or if they are still
alive so I think they must be a question
of maybe compensation to victims and
their families or maybe simply
recognition of the atrocities if you
look at this often African Truth and
Reconciliation Commission it is often
justified by as the name implies the
desire to bring about reconciliation
healing catharsis I do not believe that
is a realistic game but i think the
commission has done an important job in
making it impossible for anybody to deny
that these atrocities took place because
many whites were probably unaware or
only they didn't want to look too
closely at what was going on so they
could say to themselves that no i don't
think this happened wasn't that bad but
after the hearings or the commission
nobody could deny that these atrocities
didn't take place and where in fact very
bad and some truth is important but i
don't think it's important to bring
about reconciliation in fact i think
bringing out the truth without justice
can make resentment stronger but it is
important for that reason I just
indicated now the relation between
revenge and justice is complicated here
is one approach which doesn't really
apply as I said to his neuro but does
apply to a German occupied countries in
anger if you want to take revenge and
anger the emotion will tend to fade over
time that should predict that the same
crime when child in 1945 should receive
a more severe sentence than when the
same type of crime was tried in 1948 and
this is what we observed throughout
Western Europe somebody who has served
in a muffin SS tried in 1945 would be
sentenced to death and executed someone
who are done exactly the same thing
tried in 1948 will be sentenced to five
years of prison serving two or three
which as an indication that this is not
impartial timeless justice but at least
justice mixed up with a desire for
revenge well of course then the personal
is why did not the emotions fade in
Eastern Europe what the Polish case as
we all know as you all know better than
I do but in a newspaper reader who know
it in a polished case i'm not sure one
can talk about a groundswell of demand
for retribution in a population at large
because this was part of a political
game among another post solidarity
elites i do say in my book that Lake
korchinsky was an anti anti anti
communist rather than an anti-communist
that he was used you know he used this
as a tactical weapon in his struggle in
politan in Polish politics but maybe I'm
wrong but
so I think in these cases well the
sickness three different things there is
the desire for substantive justice to be
made there is desire to respect the
rules of procedural justice and there's
desire for revenge now the conflict
within substance substantive and
procedural justice is brought out by the
coat I just gave we thought we get we
got rear-ended justice we only got got
the rule of law so that's one complete
then there's a conflict between justice
and revenge where revenge can lead to
excessive severity or punishment not of
the innocent but of a small severe
punishment of the guilty then would be
carried out when emotions have faded so
there are two three different motives
and two different tensions
i'm from germany as i'm sure you can
tell from my accent and so i would like
to say a few words about germanium but
then come back to some of the issues yes
I am um thank you uh just I think that
seems to be a little bit of a feeling
you know that the West Germans really
push the East Germans to do things that
they didn't want to do and I would like
to say that while West Germany clearly
had interests of its own it nevertheless
was a coalition really are very powerful
former anti-communists in East Germany
and that the agenda was really set in
many ways by the time German unification
occurred and that West German sometimes
try to be more lenient and were pushed
back and they didn't want to be you know
be accused being not anti-communist
enough I think it's a complicated issue
I want to come back and you know the my
predecessor asked a question too in
looking at transitional justice what
strikes me about Central and Eastern
Europe is in comparison to what went on
at the same time in other parts of the
world like in South Africa that the
issue of what we could call
reconciliation or integration or the
need to form a political community that
those issues were really downplayed and
you know I find that strikingly
interesting because it's just one aspect
you know from the very beginning justice
was always about punishment and it was
really not about you know I mean
creating democracy can have two ways one
thing is you know to bring justice and
punish but another aspect is to
integrate because you want to move
forward and you want to create a
community and I think that I would like
you know i'm interested in your comment
secondly i'm afraid i have a few
questions essence i have regular work
too I i find it also interesting that in
the case of eastern europe we mostly
talk about what has been called
restoration and you obviously mentioned
other aspects of legal administrative
measures
it's important and I have my own ideas
why the striation bubbled to the
forefront whereas you know compensation
and rehabilitation I mean they take
place but they're not nearly as
important in the overall debate so just
your thoughts on this thing but I I'm
try to remember what my friend Ricky
Papa told me but I think she told me
that they were attempts in Berlin to
organize meetings or of Stassi officials
and their victims if not called on them
the inform is people have been performed
upon and that these were uniformly
unsuccessful I believe she told me I
think reconciliation must take place at
a higher level and my model for
reconciliation although it may seem
perverse to some of you and especially
knowing what happened in Czechoslovakia
was president Hubble's decision in 1990
to adopt proportional voting in the
first free elections now Havel at the
time basically could pick and choose
whatever electro cisne wanted his
personal preference work for
single-member majority voting because in
that way you will avoid the party
politics which the travel thought was
the meeting and you could have the
opportunity for the rotaries to choose
outstanding personalities but haven't
decided honest the advice partner of
Patrick Pete art his prime minister to
adopt proportional representation to
bring the Communists back into the
political system because otherwise
everybody that would have been excluded
and it could have been in an underground
civil war between the winners and the
losers which how will want to avoid by
adopting proportional representation now
I'm not judging the results of that
decision but the intentions I think were
right but it was a matter of
reconciliation not at a personal level
but at the the political level I think
reconciliation of the personal level
after conflict of this kind is
impractical possible I'm a little bit
engaged in their current peacemaking
process in Colombia and and their think
they have decided that rather than
seeking healing and reconciliation they
should send the perpetrators to another
part of the country than where they
committed their wrongdoings because
otherwise to have perpetrates that
perpetrators and perpetrators and
victims living together side by side is
an untenable unstable situation now the
second question why the priority of
purchase illustration of a resolution
and compensation in the region well its
first one how to quantify to say that as
I said in in the former East Germany
huge numbers of public officials did
lose the jobs very few people went today
so in that case there might seem to be a
priority for purchase over punishment
but if you another way of looking at it
might be as I said a few minutes ago to
look at the number of cases that were
actually investigated that was quite a
large number of cases it's just that
through the successive filters in a
judicial system more and more cases
dropped out until the people actually
went to jail was very limited but I
think at some point at least it was a
political will to to punish but then the
will required resources and there is
almost complete over scarce resources so
that's at least how I read the chapter
by offer and poplar in in the book I I
mentioned that the political will was
there but it wasn't strong enough to
also command the resources that would
have been needed to carry out the
investigations and processes properly
now with respect to compensation
but it has of course being in a region
extensive compensation and and
restitution our site various figures in
my book I hope they are reliable more or
less I don't know I wouldn't feel
comfortable about saying outright that
in the region as a whole there was a
strong emphasis on legislation compared
to compensation maybe that's true but I
haven't really thought about how to go
about quantifying those two those two
things I'm afraid we're out of time for
the keynote we'd like to thank you
professor Elster for going through half
a dozen countries or more and giving
good answers to good questions Thank